we've just been sent out a joint
statement from ursula von lyon
uh and president prime minister boris
johnson i should say
and i'm just going to read it out so
everybody's fully up to speed it says in
a phone call today
on the ongoing negotiations between the
european union and the united kingdom
we welcome the fact that progress has
been achieved in many areas
nevertheless significant differences
remain on three critical issues
the level playing field governance and
fisheries
both sides underlined that no agreement
is feasible
if these issues are not resolved whilst
recognizing the seriousness of these
differences we agreed that a further
effort
should be undertaken by our negotiating
teams to assess
whether they can be resolved we are
therefore instructing our chief
negotiators to reconvene
tomorrow in brussels and we will speak
again
on monday evening so that's very
interesting we we of course saw
michelle barnier returning to brussels
on friday night after those talks
broke down but it appears that boris
johnson and ursula wonderlion
have decided that it is worth trying to
get those negotiating heads back
together to see if they can thrash it
out and have another
talk about it all on monday so let's
bring adam back in
uh to analyze all of that and you can
see joe pike in westminster for us as
well
um adam it is these three sticking
points from what we know
of the three what really appears to be
the problem here
well that is the issue frankly is that
is one thing to say right go back and
carry on talking they've been talking
for literally
months and months now and there has been
precious little progress in three areas
uh those
areas are about what's called the level
playing field these are competition
rules designed to ensure
that companies for one of a better
expression companies in one country
don't get a march of companies in
another through things like state aid or
by differences
on on workers rights that's one thing
another one is governance
in other words if there is a problem
with this agreement how is that resolved
and a third very symbolic if not
economically important
is fishing and that one has been pretty
intractable because it is seen as so
symbolically important for governments
in the united kingdom and also
specifically
in france but also in the netherlands
and belgium uh and other countries
and frankly unless there is some new
mechanism which is going to
unpick these it is quite hard to see how
progress is going to be made simply uh
by ursula fonda line and boris johnson
saying go on go away and have another
couple of
days of trying to find a deal it's
possible but let's be honest they've had
months and gone
pretty much nowhere what i suspect is
going to happen is is that there are
going to have to be further negotiations
behind the scenes
there is going to have to be more
instruction certainly from the european
side
to michelle barnier about what
compromises he can make i
imagine the same with with boris johnson
and lord frost
his negotiator i understand that both
michelle barnier and lord frost were
sitting in the rooms listening in
on those phone calls that is what is
going to happen now
i'm hearing that these talks will
reconvene here in
brussels and i would say that that
actually a senior eu diplomat said to me
earlier
that he thought that there was a bit of
theatrics going on that it needed
a whack but his prediction was that you
could have a couple of days of talks
that focus would be increased because of
the looming debate around the internal
market bill
in the uk and and he thought that it was
possible that a deal could be done
by monday evening interesting that that
is when ursula fonda line and boris
johnson have said that they will talk
again frankly there is going to have to
be something going on behind the scenes
just putting these negotiators back
together and asking them to try again
i don't think will work sure okay adam
well let's bring in joe pike in
westminster given what adam's saying
there joe
do you think that we have reason to be
pessimistic that a deal can be reached
i think there this uh statement
leaves us feeling maybe a bit more
optimistic than we certainly started the
day
isabel because of course we knew that
this call was significant and would
probably steer us
towards the eventual conclusion that
certainly doesn't seem to be no deal
at this stage interesting that this
talks are starting so
uh fast again they will start tomorrow
but that
both leaders boris johnson and ursula
underline will talk on monday so i
suppose
uh the negotiators are being given a day
a day and a half to see if they can make
any progress perhaps
based on that private conversation today
between their
two bosses or the leaders will get
involved yet again certainly downing
street were very optimistic
towards the end of this week but
yesterday things changed they believe
that new demands were placed on them by
michelle barnier new demands that they
think were coordinated by
france by spain perhaps by italy as well
and new demands not just on fishing but
on
state a they were pretty frustrated
about that and uh some in government
think there is absolutely no chance that
they will
commit to any of the demands of course
david frost as adam said there is with
boris johnson at checkers that's where
the prime minister took that call and
i'm sure they'll be discussing now
where to go next certainly conservative
mps seems to be
a pretty supportive of boris johnson in
private and in public i think in
contrast
it's ursula von de line who after uh
many months of saying that
the eu would speak as one now has the
far more difficult task
of trying to keep eu leaders focused
and trying to get them to commit to a
deal kate joe pike and westminster adam
parsons in brussels thank you both very
much
indeed for that